[Applause]  his right shoe is done  his right shoe caught a flat tire right  there  [Music]  i'm not quite sure how that happened but  oh that that zion williamson kind of  stuff it it came  off the soul  sliding his feet defensively right there  planted his right foot and wow  just you're right very similar zion  williamson  he's lucky he didn't get hurt on that  play similar to zion wins in two years  ago  really lucky there was a moment there  where he was trying to process  what happened he looked down he looked  at his shoe  and quickly realized that he's going to  need a replacement  [Music]  so vanderpos is on the bench getting  sorted out  ohio is down 19 to creighton foul called  on the tight defense by sharif mitchell  and i think he's putting on a different  style of shoe right now so he's going to  be out there with some  mismatched shoes band applause